but first we want to bring you someone
you know well Brian Kilmeade season 5 of
his Fox Nation series what made America
great debuts this Sunday in the episode
kill me will speak with the president
about attacks on our country's monuments
here's how the president responded they
would knock down Lincoln there's a group
that wants to take down Lincoln they
haven't figured out exactly why yet
George Washington Thomas Jefferson
I've stopped him twice now from going
over to the Jefferson Memorial
if I weren't president they would have
knocked out if a guy like Biden was
president they will knock down the
Jefferson Memorial just hours after the
interview was recorded demonstrators did
try to knock down president Jackson's
statue near Lafayette Park they were
prevented from doing that Brian Kilmeade
joins us tonight Brian thanks so much
for coming on before I ask you why no
one's really doing anything about all of
this and no one really is what is the
point of it what is the met why statues
what message are they sending to the
rest of us just to show you how
newsworthy this is sometimes you look at
what made America great
you look back in the past I was in the
Oval Office doing a history of the White
House wanting to get him to talk about
history he said I'm he segue right over
the statues they're trying to destroy
our history now hey I brought up Andrew
Jackson because they're trying to take
down Jackson's statue in New Orleans I
turn on your show and he commented on
that I turn on your show and you opened
last night with just a half-mile away
two hours from when I left him there
trying to take away Andrew Jackson I'll
tell you what Tucker Benton by the time
you were off the air I thought that
statue would be down thankfully the
police got there or no would have come
so long but they got there to stop it
and I think in the big picture people
are trying to find fault with our past
because they don't like the country
these people aren't trying to make our
country better if you want to make our
country better no to petition Andrew
Jackson had slaves as great as he was 14
year-old orphan who was jailed in the
Revolutionary War were you fighting for
the country at the age of 14 also when
you lost your family to the war to the
British did you pledge allegiance to
your country and become a lawyer an
attorney general a judge a congressman a
Major General
to win the most decisive impactful
battle in our history to that point in
the Battle of New Orleans and then go on
to be a two-term president this is a
American success story if you want to
make America better you put a plaque on
there and said yep he had slaves in his
day and he was part of the Indian
Removal Act and those weren't positive
things but there was a generation called
the Jackson generation the Jacksonian
era that's why there's a statue you
don't want to make America better you
want to destroy our past because we
don't live up to the lofty standards of
the shirtless skateboarders who want a
petition and protest to try to
intimidate reporters on a nightly basis
they're the lowest standards and not
just a personal hygiene that I've ever
seen in any group they're totally
ignorant they're illiterate vandals and
our leaders with very few exceptions
have decided to let them rampage through
our country and I and I don't understand
why do you know I don't and it makes no
sense you know you guys guys are like
Tom cotton who won't stand for it so he
goes to the Ivy League school serves in
the infantry he bleeds red white and
blue and there's probably five or six in
the Senate maybe three in the house not
one Democrat by the way he was the first
Democratic president stand up for him
why am i standing up for him why is Tom
cotton standing up for your hand up for
him you mention FDR yeah because you
mentioned FDR hey Tucker they never told
us the people in our social studies
books were perfect they told us they
were important to the makeup of America
America gets better and better and
better we never said were perfect what's
great about us is we try to be and
that's what Jackson was Jackson was in
every man he wasn't a founding father he
had no connections to Washington they
hated him
they told him not to go so he brought
his family couldn't trust anyone when
Washington rejected him he brought his
case to the people when he lost a
coastal close election
he shook the hand of John Quincy Adams
and essentially said rematch he beat him
four years later he was the everyman
president in 81 South Carolina try to
secede he's told South Carolina used to
see them sending in the army he kept our
country together another 30 years you
can analyze his administration do a
paper on it get a PhD don't take down
his statue I am just so glad they made
his statue as tough
the person because they couldn't get him
down with chains they couldn't get him
down with ropes they can defile him but
they couldn't take him down I'm not
saying I want to be Andrew Jackson I'm
telling you if I was suffering from
dysentery and I had to lead a army of
ragtag Americans Choctaw Indians regular
Marines pirates put them together in
three weeks and beat an army that just
beat Napoleon and wipe them out in 45
minutes I think that's a pretty special
American that deserves a statue deserves
a plaque deserves your it does deserve
your respect
that's all be respectable of our past
everybody wants to be us for a reason a
statue made of hickory Brian kill me
great to see you tonight thank you so
much be sure to check out Brian's show
what made America great this Sunday
10:00 p.m. Fox Nation special airing
Sunday right here on the Fox News
Channel